يبدو ان الزواج مفيد لصحه القلب خاصه لدى
الرجال يناديل دراسه حديثه كشفت عن ان
الذكور العزاب اكثر عرضه للوفاه من قصور
القلب بمقدار الضعف مقارنه بالرجال
متزوجين او بالنساء في اي حاله اجتماعيه
نقلت صحيفه
احتمال وفاه العزاب بسبب قصور القلب اكثر
بمرتين من الرجال المتزوجين في حين لم يكن
لدى الرجال من المطلقين او الارامل او
المفصلين خطر متزايد للوفاه مقارنه
بالرجال المتزوجين وما تثبته دراسه هو ان
جنس الشخص وحالته الاجتماعيه لهما تاثير
على حاله قلبه
[موسيقى]
حسب العلاقه الزوجيه ما بين الناس عن
الموضوع
حسب العلاقه الزوجيه ما بين الزوجين يعني
اذا كانت العلاقه ناجحه وفي تفاهم بينهم
فاكيد راح تكون مفيده واذا ما في تفاهم
ومشاكل وزي هيك بينهم راح تنعكس عليهم
سلبا طبعا صراحه يعني حسب علاقه الزوجين
اكيد واذا كان في ولاد فيعني سبحان الله
هي سنه الحياه فاكيد راح يكون اشي مفيد
لصحه القلب لصحه العقل لصحه الجسم
انا بحكي بالنسبه لالي انا لا انا جربت
اول مره نفس الوجع والثاني نفس الوجع انا
عندي التنتين متجوز اثنتين
بالنسبه ليلي مش مرتاح بنفس الموضوع انا
شايف ضد
في وجع قلب من ورا الحكي الزواج اكيد مفيد
سلبا على العلاقه بين الزوجين هلا هذا
بيعتمد على الزواج
اذا كان حين على الطرفين يعني بهذا بينعكس
عليه صحيا
تكون حياتهم منيحه وصحتهم منيحه
الينا المرشده والمدربه بالعلاقات الزوجيه
ليال ابو فرحه سيده العيال اهلا بك معنا
في العربيه لماذا باعتقادك الرجال العزاب
اكثر عرضه للوفاه بحسب ما تقول الدراسه
علميه
صباح الخير هلا هي الدراسه امريكيه
واخذت جانبين يعني جانب اجتماعي وجانب صحي
بالنسبه للجانب الصحي
بزيد هرمون الكورتيزول عند الرجل باعمار
متقدمه فهذا راح يسبب نقص في اجهزه
المناعه ومن ثم حيزيد ضغط الدم ومن ثم الى
ازمات قلبيه هذا من الجانب الصحي اما من
الاجتماعي
فالحياه الاجتماعيه بين الرجل الاعزب
والرجل المتزوج تختلف تماما لانه بطبيعه
الحياه حتكون مثلا رجل الاعزب راح يكون
حياتهم روى روى موضوع
نعم يعني انت تقولي على الاعزب يعني احنا
كمان ليال اذا بدنا نوضح للمشاهدين على
هذه الدراسه هل الموضوع انه عضله القلب
بتضل نشطه مش شرط انه يكون يعني عن نتحدث
عن حب وغرام ممكن تكون يعني بسبب القلق
وكثره الانفعالات مثلا صح خليني احكيلك
هيك علشان نطلع
يعني بملخص جدا جميل
خلينا يعني ناخذ الزواج ما الغايه من
الزواج خلينا هيك نحكي بمفهوم كثير بسيط
هو الانس هذا المخزن الاولاني يعني هذا
المغزل الاول
عقلهم بجوار عقل وقلب مربوط بقلب وروح
تداوي ويدهن تداوي ونفس تطمئن وتامن يعني
اذا تحققت هاي الامور كلياتها في الزواج
فاحنا رح نحقق زواج ناجح
يعني الرجل الاعزب دائما بكون مشغول هلا
الموضوع احنا طرحناه بوقت كتير حساس لانه
الشباب اصبح عندهم عزوفه عن الزواج ليش
اما بسبب اقتصادي وهذا انحكى فيه بالتقرير
قبل شوي وبنفس الوقت اسباب شخصيه اوقات
بيكون عندهم خوف بكون عندهم قلق من انه ما
يكون مسؤول انشغاله في الوضع الاقتصادي
بانه يامن نفسه واوقات بكون يعني شاب طموح
جدا ولازم نوضح كمان شغله انه طبيعه الرجل
انتقالي ومحدد
ودقيق يعني مش مثل الانثى بتخترق كل
الامور ممكن بوقت واحد ممكن تخوض كل
التجارب بنفس الوقت عندها قدره طيب
بالنسبه للشباب العزاب اللي يتجنبوا
الزواج بسبب ما يعتبره خوف من المسؤوليه
خوف من التقيد خوف من الضغوط الاجتماعيه
والضغوط الاسريه ماذا تقولين له
عم بقول له خذ التجربه في مراحل جدا جميله
ممكن تحرم نفسك فيها كل ما كان عمرك اصغر
عندك القدره على انك تخود هاي التجربه بكل
سلاسه وكل ما كبرت بالعمر اكثر رح يكون
اصعب لانه حيكون عندك صعوبه في الاختيار
لانه حتى اليوم لما بده يرتبط به يعني
بانثى هي كمان ممكن تكون يا اما خاضت
تجربه من قبل يا اما حتكون هي كمان عندها
صعوبه في الاختيار بعدين الزواج فيه مراحل
جدا جميله بالاول بنكون زوجين بعدين بنصير
ابوين لطفل او طفلان بعدين ندخل مرحله
المدارس بعدين الاحفاد ومن اكد على دراسه
كمان ثانيه انه الاجداد عمرهم اطول من
الاجداد اللي ما عندهم احفاد اوكي يعني
حلوه هاي الامور يعني قديه لاي حد اليوم
تفاعل الاجتماعي جسدي روحي ونفسي هو يؤثر
على صحه الانسان النفسيه
نفس مبدا العلاقات الانسانيه في حياتنا
نحن اليوم نقدر نكمل حياتنا بس بالشغل من
غير ما يكون عنا اصدقاء حتى في دائره
الاصدقاء دائما مش لازم يكون عنا صديق
مقرب او صديقين وهدول الصديقين لهم تاثير
علينا مو بقول لك مثلا اقرب خمس اشخاص لك
هم اللي انت يعني ما انت عليه في المستقبل
يعني حياثروا عليك او ما راح ياثروا عليك
وكمان الشركات في الحياه يعني في الحياه
الزوجيه في مرحله من المراحل بكونوا
مشغولين في تامين الوضع الاقتصادي في
تامين مستقبل للاولاد في تامين حياتهم
وطموحهم لكن بعد فتره لما يتقدموا بالعمر
بصيروا اصدقاء ممكن حتى العلاقه الزوجيه
اذا ما كانت يعني هادئه
للجميع للعزاب وللمتزوجين شكرا مرشده
والمدربه بالعلاقات الزوجيه لا يلعب فرحه